George: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Pizza Hut in Japan and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In Japan, a Pizza Hut
pizza comes in three sizes.
The smallest comes in a My Box order
and is approximately 15 centimeters.
Our small can only be made
on a gluten-free crust.
Check it out.
Looks like something you would get
at your high-school cafeteria.
And it measures 10 inches,
or 25.4 centimeters.
Our next size up is a medium,
which is 26 centimeters.
I'm gonna take this little guy.
This pizza is so good, dude.
And our large pizza is 14 inches,
or 35.5 centimeters.
This My Box pizza deal includes fries
and chicken nuggets for 1,080 yen,
or add a Basque cheesecake
for 1,290 yen,
or get three My Boxes
for 3,000 yen,
and you can get a free side menu item,
like 1.5 liters of Coca-Cola.
Also, for those wanting a little alcohol,
you can get a My Box deal
with an alcoholic beverage for 1,100 yen.
It's called Being Tipsy set.
Ah, tipsy.
Now I'm going to the boxes, baby!
Our next size up is a $13 dinner box.
It is a medium one-topping pizza,
breadsticks, and cinnamon sticks.
This is the best idea.
If I had to go into an office,
this would be my briefcase.
This is what I would
take to work every day.
Now, you're probably thinking,
"Oh, Joe, I want more food in a box."
Well, Pizza Hut of course
has you covered with the big dinner box.
Ah-hem.
Oh, it is the big dinner box!
This is [grunts]
two one-topping pizzas
with wings or breadsticks.
That's what I got, of course.
You can also get pasta and breadsticks.
You can also get Quepapas and breadsticks,
or just a third pizza,
all for $23.99 to $24.99.
Man.
Dinner is served.
You can get chicken on
the bone in two pieces,
four pieces, and eight pieces.
That's really cute, Japan. Two wings.
In the US, our wing orders start at six,
12,
18,
and the biggest order you can get, 36.
Wow, that's the hottest?
WingStreet, you gotta hire a spice expert,
because this is nothing, dude.
I've had spicier LaCroixes.
Here is a Japan large basic pizza.
We call our cheese pizza basic,
and it is 2,030 yen.
or $18.39 US.
And it has a surface area of
754.77 square centimeters.
So that is about $0.024,
or 2.63 yen per square centimeter.
The US large cheese pizza is $13.99,
or 1,544 Japanese yen.
It has a surface area of
989.9 square centimeters,
which breaks down to $0.014
per square centimeter,
or 1.54 Japanese yen.
Much cheaper here in the US.
So, here are two large basic pizzas.
This one right here is hand-tossed dough,
and this one right here is a pan pizza.
Here are two large US cheese pizzas.
One of them has the pan crust,
and one of them has the hand-tossed crust.
Both are the same size and the same price.
We want to find out which gives you
more pizza for your money.
Let's weigh a slice of each and compare.
George: Go!
So, winner is:
ta-da!
Hand-tossed dough.
Oh, wow.
That's, like,
that's crazy, how good I did just there.
Look at that.
Same price, 25% more pizza.
Look at these!
Here's everything you can get
at the Japanese Pizza Hut
you cannot get in the US.
And here is everything you
can get at a US Pizza Hut
you can't get in Japan.
Japan-exclusive pizzas!
OK!
So, I got everything on here
in half and half
and in medium size on hand-tossed crust.
All right, so let's start with this one.
So I got this toku-uma bulgogi.
Toku-uma means special delicious.
So it's special delicious bulgogi.
And this one is menta potemayo bacon.
Menta means spicy cod roe,
and it looks good.
So, next one we've got
double shrimp with special lobster sauce,
and this one is grand barbecue.
Asparagus bacon.
And this one is potato sausage mayo.
Next one, we've got crumbling
pulled pork,
and next one, spicy pulled pork.
Selected cheese and thick-cut Iberico.
And this one is Super Supreme.
Mexican Kara Peno.
Kara means it's spicy,
so spicy jalapeño on there.
And next one is snappy potato sausage.
And this one is green
and yellow veggie pizza.
Shrimp mayo mentai seafood.
And this one is addictive
anchovy and black olive.
First exclusive-US-pizza pizzas.
This one right here, it
is the meat lover's pizza.
Look at this thing!
Can you see that?
This thing is pepperoni,
Italian sausage, ham,
bacon, seasoned pork, and beef.
That's every meat in the store, I think.
This one right here is the
Hawaiian chicken pizza.
This looks like one bite
would send me to my grave.
This at least has a vegetable on it.
I think green peppers were a mistake.
This one right here,
chicken bacon Parmesan.
Chicken, bacon, tomatoes,
and a Parmesan crust.
Oh, yeah, dude. Look at the crust on this.
They bake the cheese right into the crust.
I just love that Pizza Hut's like,
"We gotta cover every
surface with cheese."
God forbid you would take a bite
of something that doesn't
have cheese in it.
In Japan, you can get a pizza
with four different topping areas
called the Four Series.
So let's start with this one.
It's called Gochiso Four.
Gochiso means feast.
And next one, we've
got Bulgogi Festa Four.
So, let's move on to the next one.
We've got Lovers Four.
Lovers!
What?
Is this for this beef?
It's gonna be horrible.
And this one is called Kodawari Four.
Kodawari means authentic.
And this one in front of
me is Gourmet Mania Four.
What did I do to you, Pizza Hut?
It's burned!
Look at this!
All right, next one.
And the last one is Classic Four.
This is classic.
Deluxe!
This one right here,
the backyard barbecue pizza.
Barbecue sauce instead
of pizza sauce I think.
And it comes with a
barbecue honey. Shall I?
I think I shall.
Oh, yeah, I think I'm gonna like this.
Don't sleep on the Pizza
Hut honey barbecue.
This is really good.
I think this is Buffalo chicken pizza.
Tangy Buffalo sauce.
Exact opposite problem.
I think the sauce ruins this.
Too strong. Skip the sauce.
So, this one right here
is a Japan-only pizza.
So this is a pizza with a
boom!
Sausage crust
with bulgogi, teriyaki chicken,
Camembert cheese, Gouda
cheese, green chili sauce,
shrimp, squid, tuna mayo,
broccoli, corn,
basil sauce, and anchovies.
Too much.
But let's give it a try.
Look at this.
Just too much.
Itadakimasu.
Mm.
It's disgusting.
In the first place, I hate anchovies.
Don't put anchovies!
It's just
mazui!
I picked out that pizza for you, George.
Sorry, my man. Gotta do it for the show.
Here is a USA-only pizza.
It is a pizza with toppings
and sauces and cheeses
you can only get in the
US and not in Japan.
First, we have the gluten-free crust.
Remember that really sad-looking crust?
We can have a creamy garlic Parmesan,
barbecue, or Buffalo sauce as a base.
I went with the creamy garlic Parmesan.
Got meatballs, banana peppers,
and for the crust,
pretty sure I went the garlic Parmesan.
It's not awful.
When you order food and
you're, like, really hungry,
so something sounds like
it's gonna be really good,
but then when you start
eating it, you're like,
"Oh, I think I screwed up."
This is definitely like ...
skip this.
[thud]
So, here we've got
Japan's exclusive sides.
We've got chicken nuggets,
and this is four pieces,
eight pieces,
16 pieces.
And we also have plain
flavor and spicy flavor.
Let's try this.
Plain!
This is plain.
Everything is plain!
I want spicy!
Where is spicy nuggets?
And next one, we've
got honey cheese balls.
So cheese balls there,
and we've got honey syrup.
So, next one, we've got
Japanese-style tatsuta chicken.
So this chicken is marinated in soy sauce
and rolled in potato starch
instead of wheat flour
and deep-fried.
Let's talk about US-exclusive sides.
Can't get these in Japan.
Pizza Hut also got pasta.
Referred to at one point as Pasta Hut.
You can get two of these baked
pastas at our Pizza Huts.
One is the Tusca --
Tuscani --
What? What'd I say?
Fine.
No, Tuscany is T U S C A N Y.
They spell this one with T U S C A N I.
No, come on. I'm looking
it up. Keep rolling.
Ad: Now at Pizza Hut,
get a family-size Tuscani pasta
for just 12 bucks.
Joe: Ha-ha! Tuscani!
In your face!
Just an absolute abuse of Italian culture.
Here is the Tuscani chicken Alfredo pasta
and the Tuscani meaty marinara pasta.
If I can't put a fine enough point on it,
I do not want to eat this at all.
This looks like a TV dinner.
Like, this is what you
eat in your apartment
sitting on a folding chair,
one light bulb hanging from the ceiling,
eating this just right out of the oven,
staring at a wall,
looking at, like, cockroaches
running up and down.
Your one window has a
view of a brick wall.
The calendar on the wall
is from three years ago.
♪ Nobody wants this! ♪
Quepapas.
What are Quepapas, you ask?
I don't know.
They got jalapeños and stuff in them.
So they're kind of like spicy tater tots.
These to me are quintessential
Pizza Hut sides.
We got breadsticks, and
we got cheese sticks.
They both come with the marinara sauce.
We also have a marinara sauce
that you guys don't have.
Vroom, vroom, vroom!
Sauce Talk.
So, here is extra sauces.
So, if you want,
you can get green chili
sauce or honey syrup.
So, the WingStreet wings
you can get at Pizza Hut
also come in exclusive flavors
you can't get in Japan.
Here are all the sauces.
Spicy garlic is really good.
Joe's sauce seal of approval.
Teriyaki, this seems like a no-brainer,
but we're not gonna leave it to chance.
No!
Ugh!
I stand corrected. This is terrible.
Doesn't pass.
Garlic Parmesan.
Oh, look, there's Parmesan on top of it.
Oh, yeah!
That might be the best one.
Lemon pepper dry rub.
Why do I have to apply it?
Yeah, not into that, man.
I don't get it.
I don't know what Drake's
going on about, man.
The lemon pepper is not very good.
Crucify me, internet!
I don't like lemon pepper dry rub wings!
Should I be -- I think maybe
I should be rubbing it,
that's what I'm doing wrong.
Is that too much?
Whoops.
Yep, you were right. Too much.
But it's good.
Also, sauces, real quick,
we got blue cheese.
We got ranch.
So, here is Japan's exclusive desserts.
Here we've got Basque cheesecake.
We've got Lady Borden vanilla ice cream.
And last one,
we've got Lady Borden chocolate ice cream.
Desserts?
We got 'em.
In the US, you can get yourself this,
a set of six Cinnabon cinnamon rolls.
This is the triple-chocolate brownie.
I'm starting to lose it, guys.
All that pizza, it just hit me.
This right here is the
ultimate chocolate chip cookie.
This is pretty funny.
They should cut this like a pizza.
Cinnamon sticks.
They also come with a thing of icing.
Gonna be my obituary photo.
I can't believe how good that is.
This is the Cinnabon thing.
I want to try it now,
since I had it before.
I want to see how it compares to that.
Cinnabon is still better.
In Japan, our fountain drinks
are Coca-Cola products.
In the US, our soft
drinks are Pepsi products.
You know what that means.
This is "Soda Wars."
In Japan, we have Coke,
Coke Zero,
and Fanta grape,
and green tea,
and Qoo.
Qoo orange juice.
Look at this face.
Qoo!
It has light orange taste.
Classic Pepsi,
cherry Pepsi,
diet Pepsi,
orange ...
Crush right? Yeah, Orange Crush.
Mountain Dew,
and, of course, Sierra Mist.
Which is like Mountain
Dew, only so much worse.
[thud]
So, a full pizza
is 2,256 calories.
112.8%
of your daily recommended value.
Too many calories!
Ah!
In the US, our large cheese pan pizza
has eight slices,
and each slice is 360 calories.
So for the total pizza,
that's 2,880 calories.
That's 144% of your daily calories.
And both the fat and the sodium
are each over 200% of
your daily allowance.
Japan's large Pepperoni Supreme
with plump bread crust
is 228 calories per slice,
or 2,736 calories
for the entire thing,
which is 136.8%
of your daily calories.
Even more calories!
Ah!
This is a large US pepperoni
with the pan crust.
Man, that's a thick guy!
One slice, 370 calories.
So that makes the whole
pizza 2,930 calories,
and that has 146.5% of
your daily allowance.
Now, I would like to point out
that the large pepperoni pizza
is the most popular Pizza
Hut pizza in the US,
but not in Japan.
Online, it ranks about
the 14th most popular.
In Japan, one of the pizzas we enjoy
is the seafood mix.
It's one of Pizza Hut's best sellers
for over 20 years.
Wow.
So, Japan's most calorific pizza
is the large toku-uma bulgogi.
And I forgot to order
large toku-uma bulgogi!
Sorry about that.
But this one is toku-uma bulgogi.
And this one is smaller,
but large slice pizza is 285 calories,
which makes the entire large
pizza on plump bread crust
3,420 calories.
3,420 calories!
Yabai!
And in the US,
our most calorific pizza
is the meat lover's.
I also was supposed to get
the large. This is a medium.
If someone in graphics
could just make this pizza much bigger
or me much smaller.
One slice is 470 calories,
making the total pizza,
which should be eight slices,
3,760 calories.
That's more than double your daily fat
and triple your daily sodium.
I am a glutton for punishment,
but I'm not going to bite into this pizza.
It looks like a nightmare.
There's a few ingredients to watch out for
at the Pizza Huts in the US.
One is an ingredient found
in our salad croutons.
It is called
azodicarbonamidates.
[beep]
Azo --
Azodicarbonmidee.
[beep]
Or ADA.
It is a substance used for making
vinyl foam plastics for
things like yoga mats.
And it's also in our croutons.
I'm not quite sure why.
The use of this additive,
surprisingly enough,
is not permitted in Japan.
What?
That's just horrible!
Both yoga mats and salads
have a connection to health.
But US salad croutons
have actually plastic.
Yoga-mat plastic.
How ironic.
Also in the US you're going
to want to watch out for
Yellow No. 5 aka tartrazine,
which appears in these
Cinnabon mini rolls.
Oops, already ate one.
According to the European Union,
this chemical, quote,
"May have an adverse effect on activity
and attention in children," end quote.
It is banned in the EU.
It's not banned here in America.
And it is at least not allowed
at any of the Pizza Huts in Japan.
You can totally get this here in America.
Let's get some deficit on that attention.
"May have adverse effect
on activity and attention in children,"
I mean, it's having a horrible effect
on my attention as an adult.
[laughs]
I stopped paying attention to
what was coming out of
my mouth moments ago. So.
The Dew got Yellow No. 5 as well.
The Orange Crush has Yellow
No. 6 and Red No. 40.
Wonder if those are bad too.
All the color things are bad.
I have to say, this is also terrible.
Why the hell American fast-food chains
put harmful chemicals into their foods?
Do they make their food
in a chemistry laboratory or something?
Use the kitchen.
Hey. If you're new to "Food Wars," hello.
We actually have a whole nother series
where we compare the US and the UK.
You can watch every one of
those episodes right now.
Click the floating box near my head.